hey what's going on as bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and up do you know I used to
just check in on you to see how your
workweek was going now I'm just checking
in on you to help remind you that today
is Thursday if you're confused did you
take all right it has begun it has begun
the thing that makes America great
are you listening people who listen in
other countries is this way to louder's
at me I think it's way too loud here
are you listening other countries this
is what separates my country from your
country okay aside from all the great
things that all you other countries
around the world have stolen from us
movies airplanes automobiles air
conditioning the wheel okay we came up
with all of that stuff all right
and what do you guys do we get a little
fat and any of you [ __ ] all over us all
right well maybe if we weren't so busy
making up all this great transportation
we could walk down some medieval cow
paths like all you [ __ ] people this
is what makes this country great is
within the country there are 50 states
okay in the 50 states as much as they're
a part of America they feel that in
their own way they're their own little
country and not only they their own
little country they're the best little
country out of all the other 49 [ __ ]
countries and the United States we're
supposed to be united we're not united
we're United in the way that we all
think that we're the [ __ ] our state's
the best your state [ __ ] stinks and
we are united in that we're not gonna
let the feds tell us what the [ __ ] to do
dude I don't give a [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] president I don't give a [ __ ]
right so it has begun the government and
CDC is still saying that we should not
be going out and about and you know what
guess who had the balls to step up with
no medical background whatsoever the
Supreme Court of Wisconsin they're not
doctors don't work on [ __ ] cures for
diseases yeah but you're [ __ ] I'm
guessing old white guys in long black
robes there's a deciders is george w
used to I'm the decider all right
these are the deciders they decided that
they're just gonna open up their [ __ ]
state all right like that you know we're
just gonna do it here and you know if
you don't like it don't [ __ ] come
here well there's truckers coming in
there bringing you guys your [ __ ]
food what are you gonna do up there
Wisconsin I live on your cheese so they
decided that they're just gonna open
this [ __ ] thing up all right so we're
gonna see how this goes it said after
the Wisconsin Supreme Court holy [ __ ]
not the Wisconsin Supreme Court struck
down the state's stay at home order
which immediately lifted restrictions on
businesses and gatherings some bars open
their doors and taps Wednesday night as
patrons began trickling in you know what
the bottom line is I'm just [ __ ]
breaking balls here the reality is is
because there's so many people not
quarantine so many people not because if
everybody did with the [ __ ] CDC said
I mean I don't have a [ __ ] medical
degree here but I would think this thing
would have been over in like six weeks
worst case scenario all right it would
just have burned itself out but it's
still going you know pretty steady I
don't watch the [ __ ] news so I think
the only way to do it is I guess you
just [ __ ] open it up and people are
gonna get sick they're gonna get sick
and hopefully you can
fight it off but you know they've
they're making the tough decisions out
there in Wisconsin you know and if some
old people have to die in people with
asthma if they have two deaths that's if
that's their fault for being old hey Bob
maybe if you have asthma you should stay
inside of your house I don't know what
the [ __ ] they're thinking out there this
is this is [ __ ] wild but I gotta say
this good for Wisconsin jumping on the
bullet I don't know man there's a lot of
fat people in Wisconsin man and I'm
looking at this [ __ ] picture right
now that they're using and they're
they're some husky husky [ __ ] pieces
there's some thickens up there all right
we shall see we shall see I hope it
works I hope it works whatever what are
you gonna do so anyways they immediately
lifted this [ __ ] the ruling applied to
Governor Tony Evers statewide order to
lock down Wisconsin amid the public
health emergency of the coronavirus
corona pandemic so they went around the
governor of their state they just D
balled their own governor oh man god
bless mrs. Tony Evers this morning she's
got to sit there as he's sitting in his
Jam jams with the sad puppy-dog look on
his face and she has to cheer him up you
know I'm still gonna quarantine when you
say things I still listen Evers intended
to keep the order why do they keep
showing this chiropractors baffled
30-second stretch relieves years of back
pain and it's just a chick in the doggy
style position with [ __ ] short shorts
on me what are you trying to help my
back pain or you trying to give somebody
something to jerk off maybe if we make
their dick hard we can get them to click
on this [ __ ] thing and then they'll
they'll they'll figure out how to not
have back pain sorry getting back to
Governor Tony Evers or Eavis the ruling
applied to Gus Larry right that Evers
intended to keep the order in place
until May 26
oh and
fat [ __ ] booze bags could not stay at
home for another 12 days well you know
if it's a financial reason I get it
I get the bars wanting to open up
because they have to make their money
now the people trickling in there who
haven't worked in two months to get
shit-faced
you know it's your money you can do what
you want with it however localities are
still imposing and extending their own
stay at home orders meaning not all
businesses in the state may immediately
open photos showed small gatherings of
Wisconsinites out at bars and
restaurants shortly after the ruling
came down while some establishments
posted on social media they were staying
closed
what bars in Wisconsin we're luck we're
what bars in Wisconsin were like on
Wednesday it looks like a [ __ ]
Wednesday
you got some bar there you got I'll tell
you what you got is you got some happy
goddamn people in there more than a
dozen people had flocked to the stand
wait a minute
you can't have only a dozen people say
they flocked more than a dozen people
trickled in to State Street pub and
Green Bay there you go by 7:00 p.m. it's
too cold for Corona up there right owner
Tara Hanson chose to open as soon as she
could and people started dropping in
without any kind of announcement on
social media at Lenny's say [ __ ] lady
lady's tap about a mile and a half away
for employees wearing mass served about
20 patrons who stopped by for a drink oh
my nuts this is making me feel this is a
feel-good story owner Martin Marty lien
leonhardt said the bars beer distributor
had already delivered two shipments by
8:00 p.m.
Nick's a bar in plate Ville posted a
photo and video on Twitter of two dozen
or so patrons at the bar all right so
here's the deal so most people are
cowards it takes very is a very few
heroes that are gonna saddle up to the
bar the first night so what everybody
else is gonna do is they're gonna wait
and they're gonna wait to see if these
people get sick and by weight I mean
they're gonna wait about five days all
right
because their their desire to get out of
the [ __ ] house
go booze is going to overtake whatever
time you're supposed to wait which I
would imagine would be at least you know
14 days and we're gonna see what happens
[ __ ] Wisconsin everybody you know you
think you're gonna keep those big
[ __ ] pasty offensive linemen at home
and ain't happening good for them
all right who else has the balls to open
up well I mean what else the [ __ ] you
gonna do I know is making fun of
Wisconsin but at the end of the [ __ ]
day I mean less than 1% of people have
this [ __ ] thing and you can't have
all these other people going homeless
they need to make some goddamn money and
what about the alcoholics who are social
alcoholics the best kind of alcoholic
there is although it is it is fun to sit
at home you know and I mean just [ __ ]
boozing I saw a great bar the other day
I went on a [ __ ] Drive you know with
my family baggy I went for a [ __ ]
drive and you know I saw this [ __ ] it
just looked like a goddamn one of those
back east Chinese restaurants slash
killer [ __ ] day drunk [ __ ] bar it
was the golden something-or-other second
I see gold or golden in and I'm like oh
my god they got a [ __ ] poopoo platter
in there I've said this before and I
don't understand why why Massachusetts
has the best [ __ ] Chinese the best
bastardized version of Chinese food in
the country the best we're trying to
[ __ ] kill you Chinese food that
she'll ever [ __ ] have you know
there's hints of it out here which I
don't understand because I would think
that most Chinese people initially
immigrated to the west coast you know
rather than taking the [ __ ] long way
around right so the best [ __ ] would be
out here probably I would say probably
the most authentic [ __ ] I would think
would be out here I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about
and all I know is was
constant is open so guess what you know
what I should do I should book myself in
one of those buzz I need to get back to
work too I'll go out there and tell some
jokes to the fatty you know it's funny
about Wisconsin all those fatties out
there they probably look like could you
know all of you know when some of the
fat gets on Survivor and then they start
losing all that [ __ ] weight but
they're not really lifting weights so
they just they're like skinny and fat
that's why I picture a lot of Wisconsin
people looking like although I know
that's not true because they probably
went down to [ __ ] in one of those super
stores right and got a whole [ __ ]
whiskey barrel full of cheese curds
I'm sorry and why do I keep - acting
like everybody in Wisconsin you know
what I mean
eat cheese they don't I mean Boston is
called Beantown I never in my [ __ ] 27
years of living in Boston ever went into
a place and they were serving Boston
baked beans I never saw a was it called
a hearth or a hearth that fire and they
were just cooking beans over it nobody I
knew liked beans
nobody was into beans that's one of
those weird touristy things that I think
we were known for it back when you could
build a state's economy on [ __ ]
baking beans I don't know I never saw
any beets never saw any beans I didn't
know anybody lived in a lighthouse I
didn't know any lobster fishermen I
didn't know anybody who got to a perfect
storm I knew a lot of people wearing
Levi corduroys everybody was into sports
that was about it it was about it all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] Paul Revere the
[ __ ] Freedom Trail that was all just
[ __ ] for the goddamn tourists the USS
Constitution do you know many times I
drove by Bunker Hill I never went to
that [ __ ] thing we have our own wash
but I went to [ __ ] DC I went to the
Washington Monument which is the exact
same [ __ ] thing except it's a little
bit bigger and named after a more famous
president you know everybody always
forgets president
bunker Bunker Hill Bunker Hill is there
somebody named Bunker Hill hang on a sec
I get it with this [ __ ] [ __ ] up a
drill bite Bunker Hill history oh they
have one in [ __ ] Los Angeles too
it's a chain it's a chain [ __ ]
tourist attraction the Battle of Bunker
Hill was fort was fought on June 17 1775
during the siege of Boston in the
earlier stages of the American
Revolution the battle is named after
buckle Bunker Hill and child found
Massachusetts which was peripherally
involved in the battle I had no idea
Bunker Hill was in Charlestown I had no
[ __ ] clue I got to tell you this
though if I keep watching that they'll
flip in Boston I'm gonna sell my house
out here and I'm just gonna [ __ ] move
back and I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
[ __ ] do my shows Ida bought the
Whaley the way to do it is the way Bob
Costas did it Bob Costas lived in the
middle of the country in st. Louis
Missouri I don't know if he still lives
there and then that way he was never
more than a two and a half hour flight
from any game he had to cover which is
[ __ ] brilliant you know what I mean
but the bad thing then is then you have
to live in Missouri you know that's a
tough one Missouri is a tough one it's
just you know there's so many [ __ ]
bars everybody smokes there I mean it's
it's Missouri is a [ __ ] show those
people could give a [ __ ] about the
Surgeon General and god bless him too
because they get [ __ ] I bet that I bet
Corona [ __ ] either ran wild in that
state or barely had an effect why do you
bet that bill I don't know cuz I have to
fill up another 30 [ __ ] minutes of a
[ __ ] podcast and there's nothing
going on there's no sports there's
nothing look at this look at look at
Google News what the [ __ ] do I got in
Google News some [ __ ] fatties are
going to a bar in Wisconsin HHS
whistleblower Rick bright is a
disgruntled employee Trump says a head
of the House coronavirus hearing [ __ ]
anybody doesn't know he sees a [ __ ]
lunatic he's a [ __ ] jerk-off why
Trump is
taking his Fossey complaints public he
doesn't like the musical FBI serves
warrant on senator in an investigation
of stock sales linked to coronavirus oh
boy oh boy you knew that was coming I
don't understand why I just don't get
that [ __ ] that insider trading thing I
don't understand that you know your
buddy gives you the heads-up I mean we
all do that in all forms of whatever
business you're in if you're in the
business you get the [ __ ] heads-up
right all right the song that kept David
Lee Roth and Van Halen let's let's let's
do some light news here huh how about
some light news the song that kept David
Lee Roth in Van Halen fans are aware
that producer Ted Templeman wasn't sold
on David Lee Roth's role in Van Halen
when he helps sign the ban in 1977 the
[ __ ] out of here I didn't know that
that's that's humble I he's one of the
great frontman of all time in fact after
the second show he attended he started
thinking about finding another singer
and considering calling his friend Sammy
Hagar in get the [ __ ] out I don't
believe this story but in a rejas recent
memoir Ted Templeman a platinum
producers life in music well Jesus
Christ that's all you need to know right
there with the [ __ ] there's a [ __ ]
guy proud of his achievements what the
[ __ ]
a platinum producers life in music well
do I need even need to read the book at
this point he called he recalled how he
began to warm to Roth's talents
especially as van Halen worked on the
song ain't talking about love as a
performer and vocalist he underwhelmed
me as a performer geez all right
Templeton said about watching Roth the
night he secured their record deal with
Warner Brothers
boss mo Austin his stage presence was
awkward and his singing wasn't great I
was actually a bit nervous that mo was
going to be turned off by the singers
antics and perhaps might pass on Van
Halen truthfully Roth made me nervous
too I thought what am I going to do with
this group if we sign them and the
singer can't hold up his end of the
bargain I could make the guitar player a
solo artist if the worst came to pass
I found myself mulling over dumping the
singer for a strong vocalist like
Montrose as lead singer Sammy Hagar I
thought hell he might be the perfect
singer for Van Halen that doesn't that
all just seemed like a huge coincidence
out of all the [ __ ] people he could
have picked when studio work started
temperament said he feared Roth was the
band's biggest issue and that he
couldn't fix he couldn't fix it to be
sure he was distinctive as a singer his
train whistle screams were identical
identifiable in a good way
he explained but every time I heard him
get pitchy or completely miss a note I
worried that the public was going to be
turned off by his band because of his
limitations
despite being tempted to pick up the
phone on a number of occasions occasions
Templin never quite got there and then
ain't talking about love came up when he
took braids I talked at length with him
said the producer that's when I came to
the appreciate his astounding intellect
he quote a line from Tom Sawyer and then
a comic book I still don't know anybody
who can keep that kind of stream of
consciousness raps going like he can the
more I read his lyrics especially ain't
talking about love the more impressed I
became his line and that song about
bleeding for something you really
desired just stuck with me
he was extremely well-read and smart and
that showed up and his whole approach to
fronting Van Halen but Jesus it took him
a while to get there
eventually the producer concluded that
Roth wasn't a conventional singer but
his rare gifts outweigh his flaws I hung
in there with Dave thinking I'd find a
way in the studio to accentuate his
strengths and minimize his weaknesses
well he is
Ted Templeman a platinum producer bill
burr my life is a headliner in chuckle
huts a chuckle hut closer and the more I
were in his lair as well that's why I
decided against calling Sammy if I tried
to put him in Van Halen in 1977 I'd have
made the biggest mistake in Rock's
history because Ben Van Halen never
would have made it without david dave'
fronting the band all right you know
what that is right there people that's
just great writing the whole thing cuz
because what he took me so far to the
[ __ ] left then I'm like what the [ __ ]
and then I read the whole goddamn thing
and then he heat then he landed me on a
nice little throw pillow and now I'm
sitting here happy that I read that and
goddammit guess what book I'm gonna buy
everybody guess what book I can't
recommend more during this [ __ ]
pandemic I suggest that you go out and
buy Ted Templeman a platinum producers
life in music I got to read that man
it's gonna be fun who else did he
[ __ ] produce as far as I know that's
all Ted Templeman ba-bump ba-bump up a
man ran away all right Ted Templeman 77
[ __ ] years old Jesus Christ so that
means he was 35 when he was working with
Dave they were like 24 huh all right
who is this guy produced the Doobie
Brothers Van Morrison beef heart little
feet Montrose there's a connection
doobie ball the Doobie Brothers shared
all the Montreux [ __ ] Carly
I'm in more Little Feat Van Halen fair
warning that might be my favorite van
Halen album other than the first one
1984 is great - I really wish Dave would
have stuck around for the new direction
that they were going in
cuz I'll you know I was great about
Eddie getting on the keyboards was it
brought Alex's drumming more to the
front I thought because I never thought
that that guy got the the credit he
deserved if you listen to that song jump
everybody and you listen to that
probably go hey that drum part that he
comes up with the fills that he does
total [ __ ] originally at his own sign
his own sound star he worked with Phil
Collins here Aerosmith Bullet boys Steve
Stevens underrated [ __ ] guitar player
Steve Stevens atomic Playboy's 1989 man
he worked with Van Halen right through
1991 cheap trick Bette Midler there you
go there's a nice [ __ ] left turn for
you Joan Jett and the Blackhearts you
know what I want to read this [ __ ]
book Ted Templeman a platinum producers
[ __ ] a date a life of a platinum
producer alright let's continue on I
I've been cleaning up my garage / my
office and I realized something about
myself that when I first started my
stand-up career I start I saved a lot of
[ __ ] and then I didn't [ __ ] take one
picture or I think maybe I did stuff I
took a lot of pictures but they're all
on [ __ ] laptops that I don't even
know where the [ __ ] they are anymore I
save all the laptops I don't throw them
out I still have them it's funny they
like the first ones like as thick as a
phone book right and then the next one's
like half a phone book or whatever it's
almost like if there was a plague that
was killing
everybody what the phonebook would look
like each year as the plague was burning
through all these businesses and all
these people were dying and all of that
[ __ ] all right I got the reads here they
were drinking in a bar in Wisconsin they
finally showed up
okay simply safe everybody with all the
uncertainty in the world feeling safe at
home has never been more important it's
why I want to talk to you about simply
safe home security their longtime
friends of the show and for good reason
simply safe has made it easier to find
to finally get comprehensive protection
for your home there's no technician or
salesperson that needs to come and
disrupt your house you don't need to pay
an outrageous monthly fees are signed to
your contract all you got to do is just
order online set it up yourself in under
an hour and your home is protected 24/7
with emergency dispatch for break-ins
fire and more all for just fifty cents a
day and we're not the only one only fans
are simply safe US News and World Report
named simply safe best overall home
security of 2020 right now when you head
to simply safe dot-com / / my listeners
will get free shipping and a 60-day
risk-free trial that simply safe calm /
/ and make sure they know that our show
sent you from simply safe and all of
ours wishing you safety and good health
and lastly but not leastly oh it's
stamps.com they've been here since the
beginning for all of our sakes we need
to avoid crowds any way we can right now
but if you know what if you need to go
to the post office what if you need
post-its to send out a letter or
packages
that's why you need stamps calm anything
you can do at the post office you can do
it stamps calm print postage on demand
and skip those lines and crowds at the
post office plus you can actually save
money with discounts that you can't get
at the post office you've heard me talk
about stamps calm they've been
sponsoring a show for over seven years
now and if you haven't tried it what are
you waiting for whether you're a small
business sending invoices and online
seller shipping out products or you're
just working from home and need to mail
stuff stamps comp can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to pray
official US Post is 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send once your you may once
your mail is ready just leave it for
your mail carrier schedule a free pickup
prepackaged pick up or drop it in a
mailbox no human contact required it's
that simple and like I said with stamps
calm you get great discounts to five
cents off every first-class stamp and up
to 40% off usps shipping rates and now
in addition to offering discounted US
Postal Service rates
stamps.com also offers UPS services with
discounts of up to 62%
stamps.com is a no-brainer especially
now saving you time and money and
keeping you safe and all these crazy
times right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Burpee URR that stamps.com
stay safe my friends unless you're in
Wisconsin then drink up oh by the way by
the way last night I sat down and I
watched a screen of the king of Staten
Island and I just want to congratulate
uh Judd Apatow and Pete Davidson for
doing such a great job in the movie and
thank you so much for putting me in it
once again it comes out on June 12th
alright it's going to be streaming I'll
have all of that information coming up
but uh check it out it's funny movie
it's got a lot of hot and I hope you
guys enjoy it and other than that this
is usually the part where I will do a
[ __ ] read but I don't think I have
any [ __ ] advertising you know
nothing's open I mean what who the [ __ ]
is gonna advertise maybe I could do an
advertisement for one of those [ __ ]
buzz up there in uh up there in
Wisconsin
you know what I'll do this I never do
this is a shout out this is somebody hey
not sure if you actually will see this
but I was wondering if you do video
shout outs it is my husband Chris's
birthday next week and he's one of your
biggest fans
but for real he is your comedy has
gotten him through a lot not to throw
out the military card but he's in the
army the heroes right up there with the
nurses changing bedpans in ventilators
so listening to you and watching your
specials on deployment really helped you
are hilarious and even if you can't help
me
we are still big fans of you Thanks all
right well happy birthday Chris all
right
get home soon but maybe it's good that
you're out there you know I bet they
don't have a [ __ ] kovat problem in the
military cuz somebody with more stripes
said you know [ __ ] get in there and
stay in there and then they just go oh
okay I mean normally I would say no if
you just had a regular shirt and I had a
regular shirt I'd open my bar but you
have a shirt that has more lines on it
more stripe he's on it then mine does so
I will listen to you all right happy
birthday Chris and then here's a
question here I used to read these all
the time about people start and stand up
what's up bill big fan of yours thank
you I recently got out of the Navy and
the Navy as you could stay on the
[ __ ] boat in the Navy nobody's gonna
slit your throat cuz you're in the Navy
the people were fighting don't have
[ __ ] boats and I'm trying to figure
out my next move
I'm an aspiring stand-up comedian from
I'm not gonna say where and while
looking at your resume I saw you went to
Berkeley did you look up Raymond Burr or
bill burr I did not go to Berkeley do
you think that was an important piece to
your success or could you have skipped
that well I did skip it because I never
went to it hope this message finds you
hope this message finds you this is what
you if you want to be a stand-up comic
this is what you do you [ __ ] write
down five minutes of [ __ ] that you
think's funny you sign up for an open
mic you go to the open mic when they
call your name you go up there you hang
on for dear life you say is my
you can remember and then you just
[ __ ] wave goodbye thank you very much
and you get off the [ __ ] stage and
then just keep doing that and you will
figure it out it's the weirdest job in
the world where the only way to learn
how to do it is you have to go you have
to go and do it by yourself in front of
customers
from the very moment you start you know
there's no like apprenticeship or should
I guess you could take a comedy class
[ __ ] that man I I would
I mean I took a stand-up comedy class I
did when I was younger 36 no yeah just
get up there and [ __ ] do it and and
do it sooner rather than later obviously
you can't do it now you got plenty of
time to [ __ ] write some jokes I can't
tell you that but uh where the [ __ ] did
it say I went to Berkeley
you mean Emerson I went to Emerson
College maybe that maybe you got
confused with that I don't [ __ ] know
oh wait a minute I was was I supposed to
do something forever said I can't
[ __ ] remember no I did it I did do it
Jesus Christ [ __ ] losing my [ __ ] here
man
I got him you know what [ __ ] day of
the week it is here you know what god
bless Wisconsin I hope they [ __ ] open
that thing up okay
everybody coughs all over everybody and
they build up [ __ ] antibodies you know
be amazing if everybody else all the
other states just [ __ ] [ __ ] doubt
and didn't do anything in Wisconsin and
just became like this super state you
know and then you know that they
wouldn't be able to handle that the ego
the temptation the temptation
- just [ __ ] where do you go where's
your next move I want to say that going
into Minnesota is what you do next
that's what I would do I know that
Chicago is tempting just south in
Illinois but you can't do that
that's the Hitler move all right
Hitler could have driven the Allied
forces right into the [ __ ] ocean the
English Channel or whatever and he
couldn't resist [ __ ] in Paris and he
made a [ __ ] left turn and he led us
off the [ __ ] hook and we regrouped
and we came back and we beat his ass
that's what the [ __ ] happened all right
and by we I mean America okay
England they grabbed onto our coattails
held on for dear life I'm [ __ ]
kidding
yet the move is is you go into Minnesota
you take them out real quick right like
France right over there [ __ ] Maginot
Line you just take them out real [ __ ]
quick all right
bing bang boom okay and then you
reeducate those people and then all you
pasty thick thighs [ __ ] lineman
descend down and you take Chicago and
when Chicago Falls all right
I mean st. Louis is a [ __ ] layup
you're still gonna be fighting a bull
war on two [ __ ] fronts all right but
what do you got what do you got [ __ ]
west of Minnesota
you got the Dakotas I mean there's like
40 people in both of those states so
you're fine I mean the big thing to do
in the Dakotas is to drive to Minnesota
to go to the Mall of America and ride
the roller coaster okay that that's a
weekend so you don't have to go to those
people you just wait for them to come to
you all right you go further west you're
just you're just in a den of meth and
means okay so those people are killing
themselves okay not to say that that's
not some great wide-open spaces to ride
a motorcycle or maybe find a rusted-out
cab over engine truck that you could
redo okay but that's that's the spoils
of victory right now what you need to do
is you need to move east after Chicago
st. Louis is quaking in their boots what
do you do you go to Indiana Indiana
they're super white they're into the
Klan you know a bunch of [ __ ] pasty
white people coming down trying to take
over the country they're gonna fall in
line all right Michigan's a bit of a
wild-card you go into Detroit you're
gonna lose some people okay no one's
ever gone in Detroit and come back out
with their full crew that's just you
know you're gonna take some [ __ ]
losses there all right but if you could
survive that all right you know you drop
some pamphlets in Kentucky as long as
they're red and they say you know
[ __ ] make America great they're gonna
jump on board and by the time you get to
[ __ ] Pittsburgh and you've burned
your way through [ __ ] Ohio how it's
gonna be a fight though there's a lot of
tough people in [ __ ] Ohio I you get
to Pittsburgh they're a little softer
okay the steel [ __ ] factories left a
long time ago
it's more like building apps and [ __ ]
like that and they all said they've one
way too many championships to really
have a nice [ __ ] you know they can't
make it past the fourth round at this
point you know you burned through them
and then you take New York City then
that's it we'll see that's what I'm
predicting I'm predicting that Wisconsin
is going to start the second Civil War
and but this time they're going to be
successful that's the first half of this
Ken Burns documentary from platinum
recording comedian Bill burr all right
that's the podcast everybody thank god
Wisconsin's open it up I don't even give
a [ __ ] at this point I've given up on
people quarantine and letting this
[ __ ] thing burn out it's just like
people are gonna do what they're gonna
do
they got to go out [ __ ] sunbathing
and all of that [ __ ] [ __ ] and you
know what the [ __ ] he got it too what'd
he get that young people are gonna do
what young people do when I was young I
would be doing what they're doing - I
don't give a [ __ ] I haven't even started
to make my dream come true what do I
give a [ __ ] if other people's dreams
don't come true I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
about myself
old people are all about themselves
right they don't want to lose their
dream they don't give a [ __ ] about me
and my college debt so [ __ ] you I'm
gonna go out and go drink I'm gonna go
drink and go down on some [ __ ] ko vid
poontang right that's what the [ __ ]
that's what the [ __ ] young people are
doing that's it okay people I talked for
a half an hour I don't know what I said
I don't know what it's about but you
know I think that with all of these
people being called heroes I want to say
what about the podcaster what about the
person that continues to podcast without
a guest and no advertising you know I
didn't have to do this okay I didn't
have to put myself in harm's way but I
did all right that is it I will be doing
some I'm gonna become press boy here in
the next couple of weeks
promoting the next season of f is for
family and the Judd Apatow Pete Davidson
movie the king of Staten Island and then
after that I'm gonna go underground but
I will be keeping my eye on Wisconsin
all right I'm pulling for you [ __ ]
fatties up there all right and I most
have been reading up on the Green Bay
Packers all right Bob Jeter and herb
Adderley and all of those [ __ ] guys
it's very interesting and that's it kids
up all right I got to go all right god
bless awliyas stay safe during these
uncertain times you know somebody sent
me a tweet said bill I love the fact
that you don't know what adulting is I
don't know what a dull ting is but I
think I can
yes what adulting is I think that's what
an adult an adult says something and
then somebody young goes alright that's
it go [ __ ] yourselves have a great
weekend you can't say Wisconsin have a
couple of drinks for me get out there
and [ __ ] breathe all over each other
get shit-faced go out you know you
[ __ ] fatties man you can you want to
go out and go typical of course you do
you're not afraid of that thing you're
just as [ __ ] big as it is you got to
get low that's why so many [ __ ]
offensive linemen come from Wisconsin
because they understand leverage because
they've been trying to tip over [ __ ]
goddamn livestock since they've been
eight years old you know and if you get
[ __ ] trampled by a goddamn my
adolescent cow do you think your dad
gives a [ __ ] he's up there I don't give
a you know well Bob get yourself out of
the mud and dust yourself off you think
this is a bad day my aunt got made into
a [ __ ] lamp by Ed Gein you don't know
what tough is I can't do it Wisconsin
accent Oh Kirsten in front of the kid
yeah Dean the serial killers serial
killer all right if you think Ted
Templeman is a platinum recording [ __ ]
a producer
Idina is the [ __ ] Ted Templeman of
serial killers they made like five
different Hollywood movies they made
five separate serial killers out of all
this [ __ ] that he was doing is it
because Hollywood's greedy or because no
one would believe that one guy would do
all of that [ __ ] all right that's it all
I can say is if you want to go to
Wisconsin and if you're [ __ ] gonna go
into one of those bars if you're from
Minnesota I would just say be very
careful around Gaunt
Wisconsin people that have those [ __ ]
hats with the with the furry ear flap
going down all right I think that's what
Ed Gein used to wear so it might be ed
gein
Junior now that would insinuate that
that guy could actually perform normally
in some sort of sexual way what I had
Descendants
does he have descendants do I need to
look that up now gives a [ __ ] bill who
cares how [ __ ] long this podcast is
people got all [ __ ] day
Edie gained relatives okay here we go
Edward Theodore again again he's buried
next to his family in Plainfield in the
Plainfield cemetery in a now unmarked
grave Jesus Christ you know what's funny
about him he looks like a [ __ ]
character actor on the honeymooners
let's see early life childhood alright
what happened to him on the farm was he
in a slaughterhouse
Ed Gein was born in La Crosse County
Wisconsin on August 27th 1906 the second
of two boys of George and Augusta Gein
Jean had an elder brother Harry gusta
hated her husband an alcoholic who was
unable to keep a job he had worked at
various times as a carpenter at Tanner
oh boy
working with dead animals right there in
an insurance salesman
George owned a local grocery shop for a
few years but sold the business and the
family left the city to live in
isolation on 155 acre farm in the town
of Plainville in washes our our county
wash our County Wisconsin and became the
Gein family's permanent residence
Augusta took advantage of the family's
isolation by turning away outsiders who
could have influenced her sons Edward
left the farm only to attend school
outside of school he spent most of his
time doing chores in the farm Augusta
was fervently religious and nominally
Lutheran so now they're all going to get
[ __ ] through
the bus all right she preached to her
boys about the innate and more
immortality of the world the evil of
drinking in her belief that all women
except herself were naturally
promiscuous and instruments of the devil
she received time every she reserved
time every afternoon to read that to
them from the Bible usually selecting
verses from the Old Testament concerning
death murder and divine retribution
Edward was shy and classmates and
teachers remember him having strange
mannerisms such as random laughter as if
you were laughing at his own personal
jokes oh Jesus I know what that's like
[ __ ]
to make manners is why I don't read
about serial killers right there yeah
this guy's out of his [ __ ] mind
this guy's [ __ ] whacked and there's
always that one detail like ah [ __ ] I'd
do that alright that's it everybody go
[ __ ] yourselves have a great weekend you
can't straight I'll see you on Monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr it's
the Monday morning podcasts from Monday
May 14 2012 Rory I am so Rory I got the
house all to myself he is out of town
comes back tomorrow and my dogs out
getting a tune-up so I'm sitting in my
house all by myself all by my lonesome
I'd like to sit here and tell you that
the reason why I'm sitting here by
myself as I told the [ __ ] in my life
to get the [ __ ] out right like some pimp
[ __ ] and now I'm just sitting here in
some giant leather chair the head of an
animal above me in my study with a bunch
of books surrounding me that I never
read some creepy toy from my childhood
now I don't know what the [ __ ] going
on there's nobody here and I'm slowly
losing my mind I'm eating like [ __ ] head
waffles like three days in a row you
know cuz I don't know how to make them
just for one I don't have the recipe
usually make them for two people and
then there's a couple extra so you know
I just made the [ __ ] batch because
the recipe I have
says one egg so you know if I cut it in
half when I put half a [ __ ] egg in
there okay I don't know how to do that
so I'm making all the waffles and I'm
using and I'm [ __ ] I'm I'm out of
whack I'm full of sugar and dough I went
to the grocery store I'm like a single
man I went to grocery store and they you
know rather than buy something to cook I
go and I buy like you know parts of a
chicken that were already cooked God
knows when you know somebody hit it with
a truck and then they threw it on a
[ __ ] grill so for the first time in
my life second time actually I actually
had for lunch I had chicken and waffles
a staple in the african-american
community and I have never understood
that dish I love waffles I love chicken
but not together
to me that was toothpaste and orange
juice both great ideas just not together
right and I had it and I got to tell you
I still don't get it I don't get it it's
it's like it's like the Sun and the moon
at the same time it's just it just
freaks me out you know is it breakfast
or have we gotten on with that day
should be my [ __ ] pajamas or should I
be telling you about my dad just you
know I don't lose my [ __ ] mind I'm
losing my mind
and then tomorrow I leave I leave to go
do doing an episode of our what the [ __ ]
is this show cool that's embarrassing I
don't know what the show's called what's
that one with that did the chick from
party of five he's on and she gives the
hand jobs but she's a good person what's
it called the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
whisperer what the [ __ ] that I'm doing
that show doing that show this week I'm
on the [ __ ] whisperer and I play one
of the clients and she's gonna rub one
out so you know was a long talk I had to
have with Nia in order to be do too
to do this episode but she understands
that it's just art jennifer Love
Hewitt's she plays the the hand hand
javis with the heart of gold you know
it's a wonderful show
she gives people hand jobs at the end of
masu seing them and then gives advice to
their upset what would you call the
person they're dating wives and
girlfriends come in like how could you
jerk off my husband and then she goes
like she doesn't love you he doesn't
love you anymore that's why it's coming
to me
and then somehow they pour their heart
out to her because she's such a good
she's such a good [ __ ] person that
she can jerk off their boyfriends and
husbands and these people on the show
don't have a problem with it and from
the second I saw that show is just like
you know what I have to be a part of it
and so this week yeah I'm gonna be
taping an episode of the [ __ ]
whisperer
I think jennifer Love Hewitt's it and I
might have the wrong [ __ ] show you
know it's funny on my cable box not the
cable box whatever the [ __ ] you call to
the screen when you go through the guide
right above the verses network you know
scrolling up trying to find a game and
you go three channels up and then it
goes to the porno channel and you know
it's the weirdest thing ever you just
see a soccer game a baseball game a
basketball game and then it'll be like
fist-fuck part five you know and I don't
think that was by accident because if
you watch enough sports they got
basically four guys they got two things
they don't want to go bald and they want
to [ __ ] something and I don't know I
guess it's true on both those both
counts wouldn't you say there huh
speaking of lonely I was just watching
television by myself speaking to it as
if it was another live human being and I
saw this commercial for this this this
new website called farmersonly.com this
is not a commercial people this is
actually an observation
it was basically showing uh you know
some couple of ranchers a couple of farm
girls and they just walk in the fields
by themselves you know playing with
their face finger playing with each
other you know you do that when you were
a little kid you'd do that little thing
where you put your thumb and index
finger together on both hands he didn't
kind of do the little almost like
there's an invisible tiny screw you know
there's some poor woman walking through
like these a bunch of corn you know and
the cows are all concerned to the point
they're actually speaking English to one
one another you know about each of them
going how the hell they're gonna meet
each other and then all of a sudden this
Whelan [ __ ] comes over the top and just
starts singing you'll never be lonely at
farmersonly.com so it's basically their
Facebook and you should go and look at
it on YouTube that's what you should do
you shouldn't work you know where do you
work what are you doing is it your dream
or somebody else's you're just a cog in
the wheel you know are they really gonna
notice if you stop working if everybody
else is working why don't you just
[ __ ] you know Tour de France just
sort of draft behind a couple people's
today you know take a [ __ ] Monday off
so anyways check out this video and you
know what's the funniest thing about it
is the comments underneath it as the
amount of people who [ __ ] on you know
just immediately thinking out dumb
people are it's like these people grow
our [ __ ] food do you understand that
I'm sure they don't know where the rave
is you know well who the most popular
bands are or how to get from [ __ ]
Brooklyn over to Staten Island oh right
they don't how to do that [ __ ] they
don't know how to put on a [ __ ] shiny
shirt right go jump on the subway go
down to Wall Street make sure old people
eat dog food for the rest of their
[ __ ] lives yeah they don't how to do
that you know they not to do that I make
that I made corn right for plant it so
it grows they don't make it God makes it
and he makes that fertile [ __ ]
country you know it's got to be really
hard to catch herpes out there you don't
mean I mean it much spread really
[ __ ] slowly
Jesus Christ I mean even well you must
[ __ ] rub them at least two loads out
by the time you get to our house just
sitting there driving and driving
[ __ ] tornado man you pull over rub
another one out and by then you know
what [ __ ] them going over there for
anyways [ __ ] I got more teeth in her
that's a deal-breaker look now I'm
making fun of them I like I that they're
called the flyover States and no reason
to go there
yeah no reason to check in on the food
supply like you're gonna that'd be a
good thing to [ __ ] freak him out with
just show up with like a clipboard [ __ ]
you do and sit it boy well they actually
you know something they make themselves
kind of separatist because at the end of
is that even a word they actually say
this city folks don't understand what
don't we understand lowliness is that
what it is come to New York and be alone
with everybody you never heard that you
[ __ ] you know what [ __ ] them goddamn
farmers Jesus Christ what you don't have
your cousin's phone number so you sick
of [ __ ] your sister so now you got to
get your own Facebook and see the jokes
are just too easy here people you know
take a [ __ ] a pig I want some farm
animals
that'd be great I just headspace how
many goats would you need to [ __ ]
drink enough you know make your own milk
a couple of chickens you got your own
eggs right so you got that bullsh me and
I'm milk them which I know I'm not gonna
do I couldn't do without laughing and
then I'd [ __ ] creep out the goat
Jesus I need some people in my life I
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about you
know last week I made an ass of myself
as always as always and I was talking
about the the sewage in the drain and oh
by the way you know something I'm
sitting here watching the [ __ ] LA
Kings and the Phoenix Coyotes playing
each other all right
it's in Phoenix and they're having a
whiteout everybody's wearing the same
t-shirt don't you just realize the
second you do that you're just showing
the fact that you have a shitty [ __ ]
franchise oh my
[ __ ] this week I hate that it so cool
who all wear the same shirt it'll be a
whiteout that'll intimidate them they're
gonna be afraid of the crowd I will tell
you this what was amazing because I'm
watching this [ __ ] game and the crowd
in Phoenix is chanting beat la la beat
LA the iconic chair from the Boston
Garden it's actually spread all the way
west and jump sports you know so I had
to immediately text Paul virzi and let
him know that because you know he's so
[ __ ] enamored with the foodcourt
known as Madison Square Garden talk I
was talking to somebody the other day
we're trying to think of like when we
think of Madison Square Garden what do
we think of you know boxing lanyard
scanner you just think of rock shows
nobody thinks about the Knicks or the
[ __ ] Rangers other than Knicks and
Rangers fans I just it's just another
[ __ ] that's another one to add to
that list of overrated nicknames the
world's most famous arena you can throw
that right in with Linsanity Sanchez we
got it Bill you hate New York
all right I've made my [ __ ] point
anyways sewage last week this guy tried
to tell me that I should just piss in
the shower because you know those they
all say [ __ ] drain anyway [ __ ] do you
care what do I care I don't want urine
in my toes
I also [ __ ] I'm concerned with the
fact that someone else has to use the
shower how about that you know so but I
was also thinking that they went down to
different drains I would think that they
would try and keep that separately
separate and everybody was like
everybody writes me you know whenever I
say something wrong everybody do you
know it's always like hey [ __ ] right so
everybody told me that it actually goes
down the same drain and that the reason
why you can't smell the [ __ ] is because
they have vents you know which I still
no [ __ ] understand you know then why
don't I smell [ __ ] outside my house
where does the where does the the air
that was surrounding the [ __ ] where does
that go
you know and please by all means talk to
me like I'm the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ]
ever because I got to tell you I only
got like 20 emails about it and I know
how many listeners I have so there's a
lot of people right now going really I
didn't realize that but still let me
read this bill this is Bill about your
questioning on sewage handling from your
May 7th podcast on whether toilet water
is handled in the same system as your
shower water the answer is it depends
oh wait a minute I think this guy knows
what he's talking about cuz he didn't
start it off with hey [ __ ] [ __ ] he says
sewage water that has no human waste in
it this would be considered shower water
water from your dish water and sinks etc
thank you for explaining what I don't
[ __ ] and piss is called gray water what
what that does contain human waste is
called black water alright in most
modern urban sewage system grey water
and black water are treated and moved
within the same system gross see yet
another reason to live on a farm at
farmersonly.com that's gonna be
embarrassing you and your [ __ ]
neighbor are gonna join you be the only
ones on the site yeah I thought you
wanted to [ __ ] me I just was too long a
walk you know what I'm saying just bless
its tornado season you never know what's
gonna happen in sewage system waste in
sewage systems that aren't as complex or
are more remote gray water is treated in
one system black water is put into
another and usually com+
oh wait a minute I mean okay so it's not
as complex meaning what you can't move
those all down the same pipe and somehow
separate them again you know sometimes
you should stick with simplicity I think
on this one I don't think that mothered
stuff that goes into my hair and on my
body should ever have touched somebody
else's [ __ ] personally I don't care how
much you treat it it's [ __ ] gross I
got to run for office and if elected by
I would keep the gray water away from
the
backwater bring it back to the old
system where you sitting in outhouse and
you never wash your hair with [ __ ] ask
not why there's piss in my hair but why
there's [ __ ] in the drain the reason why
you do not get sewer smells in your
house is through the use of an s-curve
in the toilet sink and shower drain pipe
if you take the letter S and turn it on
its side
that's what shape the drain pipe makes
you know I deserve I deserve to be
talked to like a child is that what an S
looks like on its side all right take
the letter O and turn it on its side you
still with me
when you drain water through this shape
some water is always left behind inside
the ass wonderful this forms a seal or
block through which sewage gases can't
get through oh that's brilliant they
should have those on like subways you
know what I mean
just I have it just have it misting in
between people early sewage systems
didn't employ the shape and it was
indeed the case that sewer gases could
enter the home as far as recycle its
antenna mazing how simple that was to
fix though as far as we cycled water
sewage that is taken from your home and
sent to treatment plant is usually
released back into nature after it is
cleaned mother nature does the last of
the cleaning process with microbes etc
you know what that's one of those things
that's like a hot dog you know what I
mean you just don't know you don't want
to know what's in it that's [ __ ]
gross yet brilliant I find that I find
I'm finding all of this [ __ ] what did I
just say that three times a fight I
fight I'm finding all of this [ __ ] you
guys think I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
what it is I have the balls to bring up
the [ __ ] that I don't understand yeah
bill every week and it spans the entire
spectrum of humanity go [ __ ] yourselves
I actually began disassembling that
carburetor I took apart the primary fuel
bowls took out the floater
and all that and it isn't that [ __ ]
hard I knew it wasn't I know it wasn't
inventing inventing the carburetor the
carburetor that that is the genius okay
take it one apart I mean that's not
that's no big [ __ ] deal
and I imagine once you take it apart you
can put it back together again right and
after a while I imagine you can figure
out out [ __ ] it works it doesn't seem
that complex to make I'm [ __ ] idiot
no I'm doing the whole thing I got that
I got the whole chemical right I bought
myself little lot no I didn't I'm lying
I'm gonna I'm gonna buy this turkey
thing then you know to put it in little
you know you roasted turkey and you put
that on the side with the solution to
clean off all the parts and I'm gonna
build that [ __ ] I should take up
before and after picture with a look and
then I'll give you guys a nice go [ __ ]
yourself underneath it for all you
people who trash me because I didn't
realize that you know it's the same pipe
that the [ __ ] and piss goes down why
would I know that I'm not a plumber
you know why can't you guys show the
kind of empathy for others that I do on
this podcast every week um would you
guys like to learn about an element
that's my nighttime reading I'm really
freaking me out she can't tell if I'm
going crazy or if I'm starting I'm
trying to build a bomb we here at the
Bill burr podcast the Monday morning
podcast I'm gonna try to make you guys
is either smarter or bring it down to my
level of stupidity so considering I can
like I know like everybody's name and
number from every football team in the
70s for the most part Wilbert montgomery
31 Fred Biletnikoff what the [ __ ] number
was he that was before my time
Doug Flutie was 22 Roger Staubach was 12
Frank Tarkenton was 10 Craig Morton was
7 Dan Pastorini was 7 Bert Jones was 7
I'll do all the court of X Terry
Bradshaw is
12 Brian Sipe the [ __ ] was he was he 17
all right all I'm saying is if I can if
I can [ __ ] memorize that [ __ ] I can't
memorize the periodic chart this is yet
another thing that do that that's pseudo
intelligent thing you know if you can
just memorize this [ __ ] and then you go
to a cocktail party like we all do right
those doesn't everybody on one of those
Roger Moore tuxedos like me every once
in a while you just go out to a you
ought to a cocktail party with other
socialites you know this this is a good
thing to know if you memorize the
periodic chart just out of nowhere this
it's second anytime you say something
dumb you can just go hydrogen is the
first element number one on the Periodic
Chart I'm gonna memorize this [ __ ] and
I'm gonna [ __ ] try and understand it
it's and then I can't even say what I'm
gonna do with this knowledge what you
guys do if you gradually we're listening
to me learning all this [ __ ] and then I
accidentally blew myself up my garage
how compelling with this podcast B you'd
listen to the first four and a half
years AB who's kept know the first four
and three-quarter years listening to how
dumb I was and then you just you're
gonna hear that crucial podcast where I
said that I'm gonna buy a book on this
[ __ ] you know by the way is anybody seen
on Spike that [ __ ] thousand ways that
died you guys seen that sure what a
[ __ ] creepy ass show that is despite
the awful jokes that they have on top of
it they just show all these different
ways that people have figured out how to
die and they just sort of trash people
and say how stupid they are and they
they [ __ ] just these did they don't
try to like tone down that somebody was
dead it's weird cuz they're making these
really bad jokes and by bad I don't mean
insensitive by bad I mean not funny over
the top of it
and but then when they show the person
dead it's really [ __ ] creepy they
show these two girls who kept filming
each other on YouTube doing practical
jokes wearing silly
mess and scaring each other so one of
the girls brothers was a mechanic or
something so they got that airbag thing
and they stuck it underneath this
cushion I sound like an old lady right
now telling a death story and they
didn't know it was there no
so she sticks it there she tries to get
a roommate to sit on and she's tugging
on her roommate pulls away the girl who
put it there lands on it it shoots her
up in the air over the banister and she
[ __ ] breaks her neck and dies and
they go through the whole thing the
graphics of her breaking your neck and
then they just show her there with her
head all twisted up it's creepy
a really creepy [ __ ] show and then
they have bad jokes over the top of it
maybe the bed maybe the bad jokes are on
purpose why don't I [ __ ] on another show
and just burn every [ __ ] bridge I can
out here um hey you know what it's time
for a goddamn it's time for some
advertising here we go let's do it we do
it every week stamps calm everybody if
you're new to my podcast if you're new
to my podcast stamps.com do you like
going to the pot to the podcast to the
post office no maybe you don't well if
you do then keep going god bless you but
if you don't and you were thinking like
you know I wish there was a way it can
handle all this business within my own
apartment within my own house within my
own cardboard box as a homeless person
that I live in
but for some reason to have some sort of
internet connection all you need to do
is go to stamps com okay I use stamps
calm it's great I send out all my DVDs
this way they give you a scale you can
weigh out your stuff and you can use
your computer and you can print out
legal stamps
bing-bang-boom plus after you do it a
couple times you got it down you got it
down you can fly through it alright so
you go to stamps com
special offer for my listeners use my
last name BER bu are are for a no risk
trial plus ten one hundred and ten
dollar bonus offer includes the digital
scale and fifty five dollars of free
postage all right go to stamps calm
before you do anything else click on the
radio microphone at the top of the home
page type in ber be u RR that stamps
comm and enter burrow
there you go all right where the hell am
i back to the dam you know what I
finally figured out how to use this
computer I didn't realize when I bought
this computer I then had to download
everything else I thought with the
amount of money that I spent on it they
would have given me some sort of program
that I could have written in but I can't
I gotta go download that you know
there's another 20 bucks let's siphon
that out of his [ __ ] wallet you know
I'm gonna say I can't even say it I was
gonna you know come see my act I have a
nice I have a nice little new chunk come
see my act don't see me just come by and
go see my act car repair bill you're
right fixing your car is a good feeling
I had trouble with the passenger side
window for months it finally went out on
me a couple of Fridays ago and it was
stuck all the way down in the door with
the forecast showing three days of rain
anyway I ordered the part took my
daughter part tools everywhere dirty
hands had some music going feeling like
a man baby I just found out a couple
hours before my wife and I are having a
boy congratulations dude that's awesome
he goes I didn't really know what I was
doing but I did a youtube search
replacing Nissan power window motor boom
it was there in it and it took me
through it yeah that's all I've been
doing that's how I fixed my blender
YouTube is the [ __ ] the [ __ ] Internet
is the [ __ ] people spend so much time
writing raesha stuff and jerking off to
porn you could just you could go on
YouTube and you could teach yourself
anything you can learn how to play
guitar you can learn to play drums you
can learn how to fix a [ __ ]
carburetor anything you want to do all I
can tell you is stay away from expert
village their videos are short they're
not informative they suck and they are
like this [ __ ] plague cuz once you
get into their expert village [ __ ]
vortex you can't get out of it you got
to like literally shut your whole
[ __ ] computer down and start over
again I don't know I'm a hundred percent
for that I [ __ ] up the mirror on the
side of my car and
um I I just have to have enough time in
my schedule to just pop that thing off
I've watched a guy do it it's simple
there's two screws then you pop the
thing off then there's two more you
unplug the [ __ ] thing pull it out you
stick the next one plug the thing Jesus
let's I can't even [ __ ] explain it
whatever I don't [ __ ] know hang on a
second
sorry had to adjust my [ __ ] weight
there yeah I've actually uh since knee
has been out of town she doesn't even
know I've gone out and I've [ __ ]
blown like I think 300 bucks on tools
you know all over the map some [ __ ] for
cars some [ __ ] for fixing stuff around
the house and it was funny she just
looks at me and smiles at me like she
thinks it's cute and it's really [ __ ]
annoying me it's just motivating me to
want to fix something like you know I
fixed the [ __ ] blender and I didn't
get any credit she's just like yeah you
know yeah it's cool bill I I said what I
said I said I said I was happy for you I
was you know like no it doesn't remember
it's like you you wanted to throw the
[ __ ] thing out that was gonna cost me
a couple of bucks I fixed it for seven
bucks right anything you know you know
what it's like to go on stage and have a
great set then you come home and you
bomb in your own house that's my life
people that is my [ __ ] life somebody
sent me a douchey thing on Twitter
giving me [ __ ] about something that I
said you know and I uh I really got to
learn to stop taking the bait I didn't
write the person back I don't know if I
can even [ __ ] talk about this they
would they were calling me out on
something which technically they were
right hey you said this in your act and
now you're promoting that you know it's
a typical [ __ ] thing where it's like
this person isn't offended by anything I
[ __ ] say but then all of a sudden it
comes around to them they have [ __ ]
world and now they're offended and
sitting there giving me [ __ ] saying I'm
a piece of [ __ ] when I know goddamn well
you're on [ __ ] YouTube watching all
my [ __ ] videos for free why
you know all these other comedians
videos for free putting other people out
of work so go [ __ ] yourself all right
see that that was all in code that's for
the person who wrote me go [ __ ] yourself
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
why don't you pay for music why don't
you pay for something all right you like
you and you're not putting people out of
work
go [ __ ] yourself the podcast is for free
it's still for free
okay so why don't you go skip down the
street and [ __ ] tweet to somebody who
gives a [ __ ] there we go whoo got that
out of my [ __ ] system do you don't
understand you know what's the worst
thing about me aside from my general
contempt for Humanity is I have a
complete [ __ ] inability to not insult
and curse people when I feel that I've
been wronged you know so then I've said
this in my act even when I'm right
I become wrong you know a buddy of mine
piss me off let him [ __ ] talk to him
for three weeks finally calls me up he's
okay bro haven't talked he was
everything cool
he knows everything's not cool he knows
he was a [ __ ] all right no and I said no
everything's cool though I've been busy
but buh-buh-buh-buh right because I
don't have the [ __ ] ability at this
point I don't have the ability to to it
to be like you know listen I just want
to say that the other day I felt that
there was a few things that were said
that I I didn't appreciate and I'm not
sure if you meant him in that way but I
just can't do that you haven't called me
a couple weeks yeah it's cuz you're a
[ __ ] cuz of the [ __ ] [ __ ] you said
the other day and you know what you
would doing it don't even that's how it
goes down you know uh it gives a [ __ ]
you know you know what I really [ __ ]
can't stand is that [ __ ] guy he does
those forward commercials that creepy
[ __ ] guy with that you know what you
know what makes him so creepy is he's
[ __ ] Pleasant he's got this Pleasant
tone I think he used to do the Dirty
Jobs think I don't be still does it he
wears that [ __ ] hat with no logo on
it so you can't describe
I have what he really looked like you
know after he gets done feeling up your
[ __ ] daughter he's always hanging out
with people younger than him you know
he's a guy walking down the street and
yeah they make my girlfriend says it
looked makes my butt look better
and then this [ __ ] girls like a nice
ass and he's like that's not my
girlfriend that [ __ ] guy I don't
trust people like that that guy with his
Pleasant that hope Pleasant just even
keeled just sitting there with his hands
in his pockets just [ __ ] 100%
flatlined non-threatening that guy I
swear to God will pour nuclear waste
into the water supply for a corner
office
I'm not saying him literally but that
just people like whatever whatever that
[ __ ] images
I don't trust Pleasant people is that my
is that my issue I you know I just don't
I don't trust people like all this
Tibetan monks you know what I say me
selling them losing their [ __ ] cuz they
got a parking ticket standing there and
their orange robe yelling at some
overweight woman before she gets back on
her [ __ ] goddamn moped you know I
don't trust him you know it is I don't
like people who pray in public I don't
like they sit around while you're doing
that [ __ ] right it's funny I bet they
[ __ ] steal flat screens all those
Tibetan monks it's why the way those
long it's why they wear drapes just
stealing all this swag out of your
[ __ ] house as one of them sits there
just calmly smiling at you you know
that's why they all dress the same just
like the drug dealers on the wire those
Tibetan monks are the same [ __ ] thing
you can't describe him they all just
start running it's like a school of fish
you can't figure out what the [ __ ]
going on you know gonna [ __ ] that end up
trash and monks know whatever this is
all just self-hatred I got it when is
this anger gonna go away I'm already
past a halfway point I've already played
at least ten holes in my life I had to
have gonna be 44 years old times two is
88 88 Eric Lindros Hey
wait a minute let's see what element
that is let's see what old 88 is you
guys interested
is there an 88 81 89 88 radium radium
evidently it's what makes your watches
glow radium was the titanium of the
early 1900s it was the brilliant shiny
powerful Elm element everyone wanted to
associate their products with and sell
it to whites only they'd never have that
part in you know they always keep that
racist part like separate you have you
know but you guys haven't noticed that
[ __ ] like whenever they talk about the
good old days about baseball you know
boy oh boy go see Mickey Mantle a
penitent or whatever they take me out to
the ball game or whatever they show that
Jackie Robinson stories just the Jackie
Robinson story and it's just about race
they never do they never tell both those
stories at the same time Duke Snider buy
me some peanuts and cracker jacks and
they keep all of that ugliness away from
the game then they tell the racist part
separately you know and these [ __ ]
people with the goddamn periodical book
of this there's no difference radium was
the titanium of the early 1900s the Klan
used to shoe their horses with it I'm
just gonna fill in the shift of these
they leave out of it just as many
titanium products today contain no
actual titanium many radium products of
a century goes such as radium furniture
polish and radium toothpaste contained
no radium interesting I wonder if the
knobs of of JP Morgan that piece of
shits [ __ ] walking sticks had any
radium in him you know is he pushed
Woodrow Wilson into office why isn't
that in here you know [ __ ] this book I
am gonna memorize it don't um all right
you know what like I said I'm doing the
hand job Whisperer this week and then
next week I'm gonna be at out in Burbank
California the 25th and 26th okay
and if for some reason you ever wanted
to see Ralph Malph put together an hour
of comedy but he never did stand-up I am
a wonderful substitute I will be out
there I'm going to be
the mall people on May 25th and 26th
doing my jokes or some semblance of them
I'm actually having a really good time
putting together this hour because I
don't know I don't know where it's gonna
come from because usually I just talk
about my life and as you can tell
talking about fixing carburetors is not
exactly a mainstream topic you know
can't put together the next five minutes
for late-night television talking about
carburetors can I how the [ __ ] do you
make that mainstream Jesus what the hell
am I talking about here let's get to
some more advertising here oh we have a
new advertiser this week everybody
the man great the what yeah the man
great what a [ __ ] is the coffee where is
it Oh err it is here it is they're
supposed to view and download it alright
Jesus Christ
the man great ok Father's Day is coming
up everybody Father's Day is coming up
we today was Mother's Island today
yesterday I should say yesterday was
Mother's Day you know you bought a
flowers now who's coming next your dad
ladies before gentlemen now it's your
dad's Day coming up right and nobody
gets slighted like your dad okay your
mom she always gets nice stuff you know
unless their kids are complete pieces of
crap right but dads they always get
screwed they get a razor they get some
sort of you know Sergeant wrench or some
some PS right well they got it they got
a great thing for you this year
alright does your father have a grill No
then what is he doing in this country
you don't have a grill I think you
should be convicted of being like a spy
of course your dad has a grill he's a
man right he brought you into this world
this is the deal for Father's Day
there's only one perfect gift it's the
man great grill enhancement system
what's a man great us man great sir 100%
made in America baby
cast-iron grilling
great these heavy-duty grilling grates
deliver exactly what you need to achieve
that steakhouse flavor you've been
looking for basically what it is is you
know if you have a grill what you
probably have is some sort of stainless
steel basically cheapo grilling grates
and these are the real deal you know
it's like you went out you bought a Ford
Focus and what they're doing is they're
dropping a big-block Chevy right in that
I got I can't I don't what I'm saying
anyways these heavy-duty grilling grates
deliver exactly what you need with man
grates patented design chicken steak or
veggies will never taste so good no more
flare-ups no more dry dry meat
guaranteed take advantage of our $20
Monday morning podcast special today by
clicking on the man great banner on the
podcast page at billboard.com as a bonus
every billboard comm order comes with a
heavy duty man great grilling brush so
you can actually clean the thing too
they're made in America 100% cast iron
they're gonna make your steaks taste
like steakhouse quality if you already
have a grill you just take those
aluminum or whatever they are stainless
steel pieces a chunk off you drop these
ones right on you get a for your dad you
get it for yourself and you make
yourself some great burgers just in time
for the summer just in time for this
summer all right there you go
so there's that part you don't if I
actually was doing this live I would
take a collar at this point you know
we're talking to Mike Mike out in Ohio
Mike what's going on but I know I just
want to say I'm a big fan of the show
and you know go [ __ ] yourself I never
liked taking collars back in that day
and what needs to do uninformed there we
go car report all right advertising
request hey Bill
you've been asking your listeners whoa
what the [ __ ] just happened
FaceTime all of a sudden I'm looking
myself doing this podcast this computer
freaks me out
advertising quest bill you have been
asking your listeners for advertisement
and discount suggestion how about a
Snapple kiwi-strawberry Snapple is my
all-time favorite drink is this
Arius you want me to advertise Snapple
cuz you like kiwi-strawberry how much
are they
you need a break on that it's my
all-time favorite if I could find a way
to get you listen as a discount on that
you would be even more awesome than you
already are please please please look
into this kiwi strawberry Snapple um you
know what dude I'm gonna go out on a
limb I don't think that's ever gonna
happen you know I don't drink a Snapple
I don't know what it is
what is it is it supposed to be like
juice I don't buy any of that [ __ ] you
go to a real you go to a real juice
house no yeah one of those places where
[ __ ] hippies hanging around you want
real juice you got to go to hippies or
go to farmers you know other than that I
mean isn't it like made out of like corn
and black matter and gray matter or some
[ __ ] it's all like [ __ ] sugar isn't
it Snapple I have no idea dude I'm not
advertising kiwi-strawberry Snapple yeah
it's something that would I wouldn't I
wouldn't even a drank that in the
seventh grade
did somebody we just doesn't sound good
strawberry Snapple maybe blueberry I'd
be a daddy down with that kiwi
strawberry I don't know it's not like
the the what is that big cartoon movie
everybody's going to see that has like
every superhero in it is that any good
by the way
cuz I'm going on the road again I might
want to go see a couple of movies
because anybody uh can anybody suggest
one the [ __ ] is the name of that I'm
going out of my [ __ ] mind you know
what it is this week people I got so
much [ __ ] on my [ __ ] mind I got to
leave the goddamn house again I gotta
make sure it's all [ __ ] let's play a
game call what bill should have done
with his life I should have been a
teacher you know just tapped out
just done that right you work from
[ __ ] September to June you get two
months off you get a week off in
February April vacation Christmas
vacation you out the door at 3:00 right
only got to do is just have a bunch of
pens in your front pocket and everybody
thinks you're working once you teach it
the first year you got it down then you
just keep coming in there right 9:00 to
3:00 no extra help but I don't get it
now you'll get it you'll get just keep
coming to class good you'll figure it
out by November you know start banging
the [ __ ] hot math teacher or some
[ __ ] that's what I should have done he's
had some [ __ ] little [ __ ] car a
little one-bedroom apartment just
[ __ ] grown food out on the balcony be
that guy you know like out dies and
people don't know for like three weeks
[Laughter]
did you hear about him by the time they
found him his parakeet ate half his face
maybe a sad existence wouldn't it well
wouldn't it I don't know what to tell
you you know what I every time I do this
podcast I sit over here and I look at my
guitar and my wah-wah pedal I'm trying
to get the balls to [ __ ] play
something for you guys but the thing is
is I need to get warmed up just to suck
forget about just being straight-up
awful but I'm telling you I'm growing by
leaps and bounds in that thing there's
somebody having a wah-wah pedal that's
like makes you actually sound like you
know what the [ __ ] you're doing you know
I was gonna watch one of those Hall of
Fame Rock n Roll Hall of Fame thing
because I had like Guns and Roses and a
couple other bands that I liked in it
and it was like [ __ ] three hours long
and at that point it's just like dude go
[ __ ] yourself you know I don't want to
watch it for [ __ ] nine hours actually
put it on and I think it was that guy
Donovan who sang that song yeah the only
way down below the ocean there I wanna
be
never that went [ __ ] uh joe pesci
[ __ ] kills uh Billy batts that song
that they play so they elect they
inducted this guy Donovan and he was
talking about this poetic [ __ ] but I
couldn't understand what the [ __ ] you I
just turned it on I hope he doesn't have
something wrong with them mentally cuz I
don't look like a douche I thought it
was Brian may have any of my thoughts
over the last twenty minutes even been
like even remotely connected alright
advice you know what it is is I also
have this dress if I have to learn my
lines for the [ __ ] whisperer
and I got to get on that [ __ ] too
all right advice Kanta story of her best
friend hey Bill big fan of yours from
Canada and listen to the podcast every
week that's awesome alright I both my
girlfriend for over four years now
dumper we own a house together Jesus and
have the usual relationship ups and
downs I'd like your advice and how she
talks about me to this lady she calls
her best friend the friend talks
relentless [ __ ] about how terrible I am
and out she be so much happier with one
of her guy friends what I just got lost
the friend talks relentless [ __ ] what to
your girlfriend about how terrible you
are and how she'd be much happier with
one of her guy friends oh she's trying
to fix her up with one of her friends
even going so far as to invite them both
to the same party knowing full well I
won't be there I've approached my lady
about and she says I'm being paranoid
I've seen messages exchanged between the
two ladies so I know I'm not crazy my
question is how do I tell her that our
best that her friend is a miserable
lonely [ __ ] and they get her to stay out
of our relationship
love the podcast keep up the great work
and go [ __ ] yourself dude I don't know
about that whole thing
like why do you want why do you want to
at this point get this girl out of
you're like the other girl
like hook your girl up with guys you
know to meet instead of you is your
secondary problem at this point your
first problem is that you saw evidence
of that and the woman you're with lied
and said it isn't happening and tried to
say that you're being paranoid I don't
know I I don't I don't I don't know what
to tell you if I was in that situation
and I saw those III I would have I don't
know I would have taken the phone bill
oh yeah what the [ __ ] is this once again
of course cursing stop yelling at me
[Music]
why every time we try and talk about
South [ __ ] you that's how I'd handle it
right why is she doing that [ __ ] behind
your back this is what she's doing dude
I think she might be out there trying to
[ __ ] you know treat it like monkey
bars where she's gonna swing right out
of your relationship into another one
why else would she be doing that you've
seen the messages exchanged between the
two ladies so you know you're not quite
did you say that to her I'm not being
paranoid I've read your phone all right
and then you come off like you're dead
that's a weird thing when you start
doing some Jade Gore Hoover [ __ ] on the
person you're with and you feel like a
piece of [ __ ] snoopeh then when you you
actually find the evidence there's no
way to bring up the evidence without
without them being like you know women
can be like I just had a feeling
maybe guys can say that too I had a
feeling I had a feeling that something
weird was going on you were acting weird
and my gut told me to check your phone
and I did and I found exactly what I was
feeling
all right why you mad at me for snooping
I was right you know what I have to get
a [ __ ] search warrant this isn't a
cop show go [ __ ] yourself I was right
see that's what I do and then it's just
you know becomes about me cursing all
right
well let's say for whatever reason you
want to stay with this girl so your
question is how do I tell her that a
friend is a miserable lonely [ __ ] and to
get her to stay out of the relationship
that's a tough one because it's her
friend you know what you have to do
everything l all the way that I talk
don't talk that way but you got to do is
you have to go out and you have to buy a
sweater just ride with me on this one
all right
you got to buy a sweater and maybe like
some penny loafers and some Dockers you
put the whole thing together part your
hair on the side like mr. Rogers and
then you just sit down at the kitchen
table with your hands folded in front of
you like somebody trying to be the
teacher's pet and you just wait for her
to come home it's gonna totally catch
her off guard but you're gonna be
dressed so pleasantly like that douche
and all those commercials that she's not
gonna feel threatened she's just gonna
be a little creeped out it is just a
honey whoa why are you sitting here by
yourself dressed like mr. Rogers just be
like I just did something we need to
talk about and you just sit her down and
you just tell her that you know see I
don't know how to do it without getting
mad and cursing I just don't understand
why you're hanging out with this person
she keeps trying to get in the middle of
our relationship I don't have any
friends who are doing that and I feel
like you're choosing your friendship I
feel like your friendship with her is
more important than your relationship
with me all right and if that's the case
then we need to sell the house now you
don't say that next I know what the [ __ ]
to tell you dude I don't want to tell
you do because I wouldn't do this I mean
you said how do I tell her tell her that
a friend is a miserable lonely can to
get stay on the right ship that's what I
would say you know listen your friend is
a miserable lonely [ __ ] all right
I'm sick of her butting into our
relationship
then every night she'd go out of be like
oh you're hanging out with the miserable
lonely I want to say can you hang out
with that miserable chick tell her I
said what's up how many bad things is
she gonna say about me tonight I don't
know dude well I don't know that's
[ __ ] that whole thing is [ __ ] up I
don't know if you can't do that you know
what I would do if I was you I'd start
finding some good-looking women to hang
out with you know just in case she's
getting ready to jump ship you'll have
something nice to land on too right
I don't know do women even listen to
this podcast anymore I can't remember
the last time one Road in I'm just such
an off-putting douche overrated
overrated underrated for this week
overrated getting into a four car pileup
in Boston while listening to the podcast
ah see it Hampton Beach get out of here
you got into a four car pileup
you said go [ __ ] yourself you know what
you need to say it was over 800
overrated it is overrated well I said to
listen to it in your cubicle I'm sorry
dude
what happened what happened to your car
four car pileup you're gonna blame my
podcast for that [ __ ] um anyways that's
the podcast for this week everybody uh
no it isn't wait a minute I got a couple
of things I got to talk about I got a
couple more advertising things and I got
to tell you what I'm gonna be what do
you want to hear first you want to get
the homework out of the way first you
want to hear where I'm gonna be huh well
you hold the you hold the power you have
the fast-forward buttons you can do
whatever you want here where is where is
it where is it busy schedule man great
advertising all right Gamefly we still
got Gamefly hanging strong gamefly.com
everybody
I'm sorry gamefly.com slash burr all
right you get a 15-day free trial
free trial typically it's only ten days
but you get an extra five days if you go
through the link on the podcast page
there's no late fees new titles Netflix
for video games WWE my calm
for a 15 day free special trial free
trial 8,000 videogames delivered right
to your house or to your apartment or
right to your PC can you beat that I
don't think you can all right
so Oh Billy fat again Billy fat agains
got to take us and [ __ ] wait and I'm
gonna be starting in June when I go on
my whirlwind tour of this lovely country
and I'm hitting a lot of cities that I I
I don't think you know I haven't been to
in a while or I've never been to in the
history of me running my Yap in history
um this is the I got San Jose coming up
June 15th and 16th then I'm at the
Chicago theater June 17th with Vince
Vaughn Steve burned and uh I have no no
else's on it's gonna be a huge show then
June 29th 30th and July 1st I am in at
the Ontario Improv Inland Empire Ontario
California
um and I [ __ ] hate that gig am I
gonna lie to you it's not the gig I hate
that [ __ ] drive that drive is the
worst I'll give a [ __ ] what time you
drive out there it's nine hours of
[ __ ] traffic no traffic you know I
could get out there in 45 minutes with
traffic you know it's gonna be like
three hours and I'm actually
contemplating getting a hotel sitting in
a hotel 45 minutes drive from my house
but whatever the shows are gonna be
great
July 14th to be at the Hampton Beach Co
Casino ballroom Newport yachting Center
July 15th Caroline's on Broadway 26 to
the 29th of July they come the weird
ones Orlando Florida Orlando Florida
September 7th 8th and 9th I'm gonna be
at the Brea improv on the 21st 22nd and
23rd of September and I also know I have
a date in in North Carolina
let me see if I can find that date for
you hang on a second
all right there it is I'm gonna be at
the the comedy zone in Charlotte North
Carolina September 13th 14th and 15th
hanging around for that Panthers game on
Sunday and then also I am gonna be at
the comedy zone in Jacksonville Florida
on September 27th 28th and 29th hanging
out to see the Jaguars playing the
Bengals I'm knocking off all the
football teams I haven't seen this year
while whilst building my new hour and
right about then my new hour will be
coming out so there you go I got a
couple of down-home ones orlando
jacksonville in charlotte north carolina
now I know people Orlando that you think
you hit because Shaq lives there as does
Tiger Woods you know I don't know I have
you know what I don't know anything
about I don't anything about Orlando
Florida what do you guys do there you
got that the [ __ ] old-ass Disney
World is that what it is the Epcot
Center that was actually built when
Rubik's Cube was still fascinating is
that still good down there Disney World
I haven't been there since I was at one
last time I was there last time I was
there the [ __ ] Epcot Center looked
like the Death Star and one of those
when they were just building it one of
those Star Wars movies that those nerds
like to watch you know I hate to tell
you guys how much I [ __ ] hate Star
Wars
I hate Star Wars so much that I only
like Empire Strikes Back because he
almost kills Han Solo and he chops his
hand off right no wait that was Luke
Skywalker right all the nerds just
freaked out how could you confuse him
yeah it just wasn't into it and I also
thought you Baca was [ __ ] useless
I mean Chewbacca was basically Bigfoot
they just gave it a different name
typical Hollywood movie you know steal
an idea give it a different name and
then stand there being like what what
I don't know you any money you know that
Chewbacca like fought the Six Million
Dollar Man like six years earlier on
television Tom with his Bionic guy right
and they fought each other and then a
few years later he's at ease in space no
wait that would the Bigfoot was Andre
the Giant yeah and all he did was fill
in his face and then he had Chewbacca I
just didn't [ __ ] get I didn't
understand Chewbacca was a [ __ ] like
an orangutan or something rang at an I
would say rang a Tang like the drink
rang at an that's what it was right why
are you shooting a gun did Han Solo go
run up to Darth Vader and try to bite
his neck like a [ __ ] tiger I didn't
get I didn't like I didn't like
Chewbacca I didn't like how he sat
upright you know I mean I didn't like
that holy I didn't I just didn't like it
and I hated the [ __ ] robots you know
I thought c-3po was just a ripoff of
that dude from lost in space the gay guy
running around how the [ __ ] did that guy
ever end up on a space trip I mean he
just didn't have that he just didn't
have the didn't have the I don't know
what's the word I'm looking for he just
another the chemical makeup to do like
the guy was like absolutely scared of
his own [ __ ] shadow why in god's name
would he get on a spaceship and travel
through space when do you stay at home
you know
well [ __ ] bill you don't understand how
planes fly yet you get up you get on one
every [ __ ] week don't you the hell
was I talking about it's trying to work
our way back here six million dollar man
[ __ ] Bigfoot sasquatch Oh Epcot sell
the [ __ ] Disneyland I mean it's got
to look like the goddamn projects at
this point doesn't it did they keep it
up the
they work on it I mean what can they
really offer you at this point did they
make the rides bigger for all the
fatties people weren't nearly as fat the
last time I went there when I went down
there the big thing to do is when you
went to Florida was you got one of those
mesh shirts that had the number on it
and it said Florida 78 79 or 180 that
was like a big deal and you pulled you
tube socks up to your knees you had a
little Larry Bird shorts on and you were
probably wearing adidas Dragons or
either Nike Cortez or the the nylon ones
the blue ones with the yellow stripe or
swoosh I think that was about it
and then the broke kids were wearing
Thom McCann's you know and their socks
said the elastic thing was [ __ ] up up
top that was it that's the last time I
went there oh no wait I went there about
a year ago didn't have two years ago I
don't [ __ ] know Florida's a weird
state you know we got all that money
down there in Miami and other than that
you got a bunch of people living with
mosquitoes trying to act like they got
money you know even the mansions down
there in Florida they look like the
[ __ ] Cheesecake Factory you don't
they you like some like Americanized
version of like a Mexican restaurant and
they have like those man-made like fake
lagoons they put people out there and
like every other day like somebody gets
like murdered or a hurricane hits their
house it's just a horrible [ __ ] state
and I'm gonna be performing there on oh
[ __ ] you know when I got into I got into
the [ __ ] NBA playoffs I finally got
into it and I'm loving it now back into
basketball I got no choice the Bruins
were knocked out but I got to tell you
that I [ __ ] hate that I hate the
officiating the officiating is the
[ __ ] worst you can't even like bump
into anybody you can't go near anybody
there's any sort of touching of human
beings those [ __ ] jerk-offs blow the
whistle and they just they kill the
drama just let him play the [ __ ] game
you know what's the worst yesterday was
I was watching the Lakers playing Denver
and Pau Gasol the worst thing that ever
happened was Pau Gasol got called out
for being soft they called him the Tin
Man
after that were they lost to the Celtics
in the finals so now he's like trying to
be this hard-ass guy so anytime like
he'll like he's trying to tip the ball
he tips it up again tips it up again
then it finally goes in then he tries to
do the Kevin Garnett you know primal
scream right he tries to act like he's
just [ __ ] badass but anytime he gets
called for a foul you see the real him
he'll tip it in he'll Dunkel do all this
stuff and stand there gonna punch in his
chest and then like the second they call
a foul on me he says like it was his
[ __ ] mouth hanging open and just
shaking his head you know he just seems
like he'd ever really like soft
handshake
you know it's probably good at playing
the piano I'm just not buying it so what
do you guys take the next round look at
me talking basketball I don't know sure
about it I still only know for Celtics I
know the big four that's it I don't know
anybody else I haven't watched I haven't
watched one [ __ ] game this year I
went to one basketball game went to the
Lakers Oklahoma game when Metta World
Peace threw an elbow and I love how
everybody judged him about that oh well
he's names Metta World Peace but he
[ __ ] elbow somebody in the head
that's not too peaceful is it right what
about God you know he's supposed to be
you know the the king of peace and all I
hear is how he's mad at me and his sons
gonna come down here and murder a bunch
of people throwing lightning bolts in
the back of some [ __ ] seven-headed
horse you know what you'd do if if Metta
World Peace was the second coming of
Christ
wouldn't that be [ __ ] awesome I would
love to go to some Aryan meeting after
that if they just proved it without a
[ __ ] doubt that that was the Son of
God
[Laughter]
do you know how much i pray for [ __ ]
like that
I like for the toughest guy in the NFL
to just come out of the closet and say
he's gay and then continuing to kick the
[ __ ] out of people those are the kinds
of things that I want to see you know at
this point I mean what the [ __ ] else you
gotta do right they have cars that are
gonna start parking themselves you see
that the ditzy broad they had in the car
that Ford Focus commercial with that
douche with the Hat with no label on it
you know she's just saying like oh my
god that car's like parking itself what
was that movie with that stupid little
robot the cartoon and and it had people
in the future and they were so fat that
they couldn't [ __ ] move they just
sort of sloshed around and didn't have
like remote control wheel barrels you
remember that there was a little robot
that looked like a blender and of course
it had some sort of relationship with
like a [ __ ] I don't know nail gun
I don't I don't remember movies there's
got to be a love story that's got to be
hard I don't know what the [ __ ] movie
was you know what it was
it's called iPod wall-e wasn't there
some wall-e
in there I don't know whatever but they
said everyone's gonna be so fat in the
[ __ ] future that they that we stopped
we didn't have legs anymore and all
these people got [ __ ] offended and
here they are they're making all this
[ __ ] you don't have to think anymore
does that even make sense you do have to
think don't you
you know I this is one of these podcasts
I should have ended 10 minutes ago
because every you know I sell right now
I sound like somebody who says they
didn't commit the murder and I'd keep
hanging around talking just further
convicting myself I keep saying I'm not
dumb and I just keep doing things to say
otherwise all right here's the deal I'm
doing the the [ __ ] Whisperer this
week and then I'm performing it flappers
that's my make you jealous and in June
that I'm doing some other stuff and just
come on out and see me and let me send
me some stuff some movies that I should
go see that I'll then forget
and spliced together with other movies
you guys gonna laugh at me that's it
hey keep going - why Amazon calm through
my website go to billboard.com click on
the podcast page and click on the banner
for amazon if you want to go buy
something if you do buy something
they'll kick me back a percentage it
doesn't cost you any more money and 10%
of that goes to the Wounded Warrior
Project
if amazon.com ever gives me any money
that's how businesses anyways that's the
podcast for this week go [ __ ] yourselves
my predictions I want to say the Kings
are gonna beat Phoenix at this point
that game should be over I want to say
it but there's just something about you
know I don't want to jinx um LA's never
won a Stanley Cup right neither is
Phoenix but they haven't been waiting
that long so I got a roof for LA and
then you got the New York Rangers versus
the the kunti New Jersey Denver's Denver
New Jersey Devils and I don't know I
think the Devils are gonna win just
because they just may play that [ __ ]
goddamn defense and you can't get around
it then he got dumping in and chasing
I'll have [ __ ] [ __ ] who knows
that's the podcast for this week go [ __ ]
yourselves I will see you next week god
bless and that's it alright see ya